[Musique]
bonjour juste un vote parce que vous êtes
s'il vous plaît bonne
journée c'est mon histoire je suis divorcé
très heureusement monsieur oui j'appelle ceux qui
choisissent d'avoir un enfant toute seule
c'est ça non c'est spectaculairement
élaboré papa aligné ouais  point pris
et puis un jour l'avocat je pense que
vous devriez avoir la pièce jointe peut-être
que vous trouverez comme un élan intéressant mais douloureux
d'il y a longtemps le vôtre
Sarah Ford quelqu'un que vous connaissiez vous a laissé
le journal qu'il est actuellement avec mrs.
La fille de Ford Veronica donc elle l'a
le journal désolé qui l'a mon
ex-petite amie Veronica bonjour Anthony
Veronica j'étais amoureux
et peu de temps après elle m'a quitté pour mon
meilleur ami et j'ai fait quelque chose d'
impardonnable je n'ai pas à mourir j'ai brûlé
j'ai le droit de savoir ce que c'est
légalement oui alors qu'est-ce que c'est que de sangloter
profondément shorty dis-moi que c'est
horrible c'était un accident alors que
faisais-tu là-bas je ne peux qu'imaginer à quel point c'est
difficile tu ne peux pas nous ne saurons peut-être
jamais la vérité  Je pensais que j'avais le temps de le
réparer tout ce que tu lui as dit ces
derniers jours tu m'as dit pour la
toute première fois c'est ce dont je me souviens
mais ce dont tu te souviens finalement n'est pas
toujours ce dont tu es réellement témoin
pourquoi  tu pars est-ce qu'on a vraiment besoin de
faire ça trop peu trop tard
[Musique] et
si le temps pouvait revenir
en arrière pour nous rappeler que notre vie est une histoire que nous nous
sommes racontée
et c'est mon histoire